Steve: Buenos días o buenas tardes, no sé.
Laura: Buenas tardes.
Steve: Tengo el gran placer de
poder hablar con una políglota española.
Que vive en Alemania,
que enseña idiomas a través
del internet, que se llama Laura.
Originaria de Barcelona.
Buenas tardes, Laura.
Laura: Buenas tardes, Steve.
El honor es mío la verdad.
Estoy muy contenta de
conocerte y de hablar contigo.
Me encantan tus videos,
es increíble poder conocerte.
Muchas gracias.
Steve: Demasiado... ¿Cómo se dice?
Polite.
¿Cómo se dice "polite" en español?
Laura: Ah ehmm...sí.
Demasiado...
Ay, ¿Ves?
Me pasa eso.
Como políglota, somos un poco
bilingual y se nos olvidan las palabras.
Steve: ¿Amable?
Bueno, vamos con amable.
Laura: Si, bien educada.
Steve: ¿Bien educada?
Pero bueno, amable.
Laura: Es que es la verdad Steve,
porque yo veo tus videos
y hombre, como poliglota pues es normal,
¿no?
Que nos inspires a todos.
Bueno, creo que hablo
por otra gente también.
Porque si, eres una inspiración.
Y nada, me hace ilusión hablar contigo.
Steve: Bueno, gracias.
Si a los oyentes les gustan mis videos,
pueden hacer click sobre la
campana para recibir noticias.
Un tema que se me
viene a la cabeza es que,
el español no es el
mejor idioma que hablo,
pero más o menos puedo usar el español.
Sin embargo, siempre hay palabras,
que se te olvidan, que no conoces,
que no se pueden buscar en el
momento que quieres utilizarlas.
Por ejemplo "polite".
¿Cómo se dice polite?
Hay muchos ejemplos.
Ahora estoy confundiendo
español y portugués, sobre todo.
Creo que muchas veces, las
personas que estudian idiomas
sienten una frustración
de no poder buscar la palabra
en el momento que quieren
utilizar esta palabra.
Y esto no tiene ninguna importancia,
solo el hecho de no sentirse tan bien.
Que parece más terrible de lo que es.
Es una cuestión de orgullo.
Pero no tiene ninguna significación.
No es tan importante.
Laura: Exacto, totalmente.
Eso a mí me pasa mucho,
porque mira, yo vivo en Alemania.
Y como he aprendido tantos idiomas,
y llevo ya 10 años en Alemania,
y mi día a día es en alemán.
Mis lenguas maternas
son el catalán y el español,
pero incluso olvido mis
propias lenguas maternas.
A veces estoy hablando con mis padres
y digo "¿Cómo se decía eso?"
Entonces yo siempre
digo que esto es normal.
Por ejemplo, en mi canal,
que se llama "Couch polyglot",
lo que intento transmitir es
que, cometer errores es normal.
Que es humano, y que aprender
idiomas tiene que ser para pasarlo bien.
Ese tiene que ser el objetivo.
Y no obsesionarse.
"He dicho esta palabra mal" o
"¿Cómo es que se dice esto?"
Pues puedes refrasearlo.
Creas la frase de manera diferente
y ya está.
Steve: Exactamente.
Bueno, una cuestión.
En el caso del ucraniano...
porque en Ucrania, la gente habla
la mitad normalmente en ruso,
y la otra mitad normalmente, ucraniano.
Pero existe también un idioma
que se llama "Súrzhik" en Ucrania.
Que es una mezcla.
Porque es inevitable que las
personas vayan a confundirse.
Van a utilizar palabras de ruso
en el ucraniano, y a la inversa.
Existe este fenómeno
también en Catalunya.
Porque los dos idiomas
tienen mucho del otro.
¿Puede ocurrir que una persona
piense que habla en español
pero utilice palabras del catalán?
O al inverso, que hablando
catalán utilice palabras del español.
Laura: Si, eso pasa mucho.
De hecho, incluso,
cuando hablo en catalán,
hay algunos "castellanismos",
que se le llaman,
que están muy incorporados.
Por ejemplo, en vez de
decir "ve" decimos "buenu".
Lo "Catalanizamos" un poco,
No decimos bueno, decimos buenu.
Cosas así, ¿no?
Y eso forma parte del día a día.
Yo en mis videos intento evitar eso,
pero en realidad la gente habla así.
En la calle se mezclan
un poco los idiomas.
O a veces pasa que estas contando
una anécdota, estas hablando en catalán
y una frase así graciosa
la dices en español.
Eso puede pasar, por ejemplo.
Y también al revés.
Personas que piensan que una cierta
palabra es española,
pero en realidad
es por influencia del catalán.
Yo creo que eso es inevitable,
porque están en contacto las lenguas.
Steve: Si, es inevitable.
Es así.
Que las lenguas terminen evolucionando.
En el inglés, por ejemplo, hay
ahora pocas personas que utilizan
por ejemplo,"Whom" "To whom?"
"Are you speaking?" "To whom?"
Yo lo utilizo porque soy viejo
y todavía utilizo el "whom".
Ahora hay gente que
dice "I would have went".
Que está muy mal.
Me hace mal a los oídos.
Pero es posible que en 50 años
sea normal, ¿no?
Porque los idiomas siempre
están cambiando o evolucionando.
Espero que el idioma
catalán sobreviva.
Laura: Oh, eso espero yo también.
La verdad que sí, veremos.
Steve: Tu canal, del que voy a
dejar un enlace en la descripción,
que se llama "Couch polyglot", ¿verdad?
Laura: Sí.
Steve: ¿De qué se trata?
¿Cuál es la meta?
¿Qué quieres lograr
con esta plataforma?
Laura: Mira, eso fue muy espontáneo.
Fue al principio de la pandemia.
Y yo soy una persona
muy extrovertida
y me estaba subiendo por las paredes
del stress y de no saber que pasaría.
Y dije "Uy, necesito una nueva afición.
Voy a crear un canal de YouTube".
Y fue así.
Y entonces yo decidí crear
videos en diferentes idiomas.
Por ejemplo, creo videos para
enseñar catalán, español y alemán.
Que son como mis lenguas más fuertes.
Luego también creo videos
mostrando como aprendo italiano,
como aprendo sueco,
haciendo experimentos,
haciendo entrevistas
con otros políglotas.
Entonces es como un poco mezclado.
No es solo una lengua,
sino que es así un popurrí.
Steve: Si, si, sí.
Muy bien.
Y después de esta entrevista,
vamos a hablar por tu canal
en diversas lenguas,
para mostrar esta cuestión.
Yo creo que el hecho de
poder hablar muchos idiomas,
5, 4, 6, 7...
está al alcance de todos.
Las personas no necesitan talento,
necesitan el interés.
Y el cerebro es muy flexible.
Puede, no todo a la vez,
pero un idioma después del otro
pueden aprender 4, 5, 6, idiomas.
Y hablarlos bastante bien.
Yo cuando digo que hablo 20 idiomas,
no quiere decir que
hablo 20 idiomas bien. No.
Tengo como 5, 6 idiomas que hablo bien.
Hay otros 5 que hablo,
pero ya no tan bien.
Y otros con gran dificultad.
Pero es siempre para mi muy
divertido aprender y descubrir
idiomas, culturas y todo eso.
Y todo el mundo puede hacerlo.
Si tiene este interés
y esta motivación.
Laura: Si, eso lo
he visto de verdad.
Porque tengo una amiga, que le
costaba mucho el inglés en la escuela.
También es verdad que en la escuela
se enseña de forma muy teórica.
Tal vez pues no se despierta
el interés de los alumnos y tal.
Bueno, tal vez ha cambiado.
Pero luego, más adelante,
se enamoró de un chico francés
y aprendió el francés muy rápido.
Entonces pues ahí tenia
una motivación muy fuerte,
y entonces en ese
momento si se dio cuenta
"Ah, soy capaz de aprender idiomas".
Pero a veces falta
un poco la motivación.
Y hay mucha gente
que tiene la creencia de
"Como no pude aprender inglés
de adolescente, o de pequeño,
es que ya no tengo talento
o ya no voy a ser capaz".
Y hay que cambiar un
poco esa mentalidad.
Es lo que tú dices, yo pienso que
todo el mundo puede aprender idiomas.
Yo también lo creo.
Steve: Yo creo que el hecho
de que en las escuelas enseñen
reglas de gramática hace que
la gente piense que necesite memoria,
Y necesite una capacidad
de comprender esas reglas.
Pero, de hecho, si no tienes suficiente
input de experiencia con este idioma,
todas las explicaciones no valen nada.
Por eso es que digo siempre,
que deben permitir a la gente
estudiar el idioma que les interesa.
Por ejemplo, en Canadá,
todos los anglófonos,
tienen que aprender el francés.
Si alguien no quiere
aprender francés,
no va a aprender francés para
tener un sentido de patriotismo.
Si alguien quiere
aprender español o chino,
que le dejen aprender
el idioma que le gusta.
Y después pueden aprender
el francés, cuando quieran.
Entonces yo creo que, la
manera de enseñar idiomas
en las escuelas, ha
hecho mucho daño.
Las personas que están interesadas,
están interesadas de igual manera.
Laura: De todos modos, sí.
Pero yo, por ejemplo, el primer idioma
que aprendí digamos conscientemente,
fue el inglés.
Pero mirando atrás, me doy
cuenta que lo aprendí con música,
que me interesaba y me gustaba.
Con los libros de Harry Potter,
que no quería esperar a
que saliera la traducción.
Cosas así.
Entonces no fueron esas
clases de gramática en la escuela.
Y luego lo piensas y dices:
"Ostras, tantos años estudiando en
la escuela y la gente no habla inglés".
En España mucha gente no habla inglés.
Y es un poco triste, ¿no?
Porque tantas horas dedicadas,
y si se hiciera de una
forma un poco diferente,
pues tal vez la gente hablaría más.
Steve: Dígame, yo tengo la impresión,
de que los portugueses, hablan
mejor el inglés que los españoles.
¿Estás de acuerdo?
Laura: Si, yo tengo
esa impresión también.
Bueno, esa fue mi impresión
cuando fui a Portugal de viaje.
Me di cuenta de que claro,
hablan portugués, español e inglés.
Claro, también en zonas así más turísticas.
Pero yo creo que en
general del español,
la gente piensa que como es
una lengua con tantos hablantes,
como que no "necesito" el inglés.
Si ves países más pequeños,
como por ejemplo en Suecia,
la gente habla bien inglés.
En Alemania también en general.
Steve: Yo creo que el caso de
Portugal y el español es muy interesante.
Es el hecho de que bueno
España es más grande que Portugal.
Hay más hablantes de
español que de portugués.
Aunque en Brasil hay
como 200.000.000.
Y también el hecho de que hay
más sonidos me parece, ¿no?
En portugués que en español.
Las vocales.
Hay más variedad de vocales
en portugués que en español.
Pero también el hecho
de que, en Portugal,
los programas de televisión
son en versión original.
Lo que no es el caso en España.
Laura: Ah, eso ayuda.
Steve: Y en Suecia o en Holanda,
todos los programas de televisión son
en inglés, francés, alemán, lo que sea.
Pero en España no. Son doblados.
Creo que son doblados.
Laura: Exacto.
Si, si, sí. Es así.
Y entonces yo también tengo amigos
que quieren aprender
inglés a veces,
y se ponen por ejemplo "Friends",
pero se lo ponen con
subtítulos en español.
Y yo pienso "No, ponéroslo
con subtítulos en Inglés".
Porque el cerebro yo creo que
siempre escoge como la opción más fácil.
Que, en ese caso, es leer en español.
Entonces yo por ejemplo, es lo que digo.
Lo que decías de las vocales,
lo que es interesante
por ejemplo, en catalán hay 8.
entonces eso también...
Y bueno, el hecho de crecer bilingüe
aunque sean lenguas parecidas,
también ayuda.
Yo creo.
Steve: Yo creo que el
caso de los catalanes,
que han aprendido desde
su infancia catalán y español,
debe hacer que sus
cerebros sean más flexibles.
En principio.
Entonces quizás que los
catalanes hablan mejor otros idiomas
que alguien de Madrid.
Laura: Si, pero bueno por
ejemplo yo creo que si alguien habla
por ejemplo, vasco y español,
incluso mejor en ese sentido.
Porque al ser lenguas tan diferentes.
Pero bueno, también hay mucha gente
que habla fatal el inglés de Catalunya, eh.
O sea, como en todas partes.
Steve: Dígame, las
complicaciones gramaticales.
Por ejemplo, en español o catalán,
para muchos es la
cuestión de los verbos.
Con las conjugaciones.
Laura: Conjugación.
Steve: Pero en alemán,
esta este problema
de lo que se llama en
inglés "Declensions".
Son los subjuntivos que cambian.
Laura: Horrible.
Steve: ¿Cómo has podido sobrepasar
este obstáculo, aprendiendo el alemán?
Laura: Bueno, sí y no.
Ja und nein
Porque en realidad te diré,
yo hablo bastante bien el alemán,
yo diría que tengo un nivel C1.
Pero no lo hago siempre todo perfecto.
A veces se me olvida.
¿Esto es da, die, das?
Pero sí que hay unas reglas,
y es lo que tu decías,
sí tenemos mucho input
el cerebro se acuerda.
Pues hay ciertas estructuras
que se automatizan.
Y es lo mismo que
pasa con el da, die, das.
Lo que pasa es que a veces
también hay que poner esa atención,
porque yo conocí a un chico que
decidió que él no iba a aprender eso.
Él dijo "Yo voy a decir siempre da"
Siempre da.
Y yo dije okey, bueno.
Te van a entender.
Pero yo creo que esa
es una mala estrategia.
Tampoco hay que ir al
otro extremo de decir,
lo quiero decir todo perfecto.
Bueno, va a ser difícil.
A partir de una cierta edad,
llegará esa perfección.
Yo creo que es imposible,
o casi imposible.
En mi opinión.
Steve: Si, yo estoy de acuerdo.
La mayoría de la gente
quiere hablar correctamente.
Quiere hablar según el "usage".
Como usan el idioma los nativos.
Esa es la meta.
Yo quiero hablar como los alemanes.
Pero si voy a estar pensando
todo el tiempo si este es die, das, da,
no voy a poder hablar.
Entonces hay un equilibrio.
Si, quiero hablar mejor.
Pero sé que estudiando las...
¿Cómo se dice?
"the tables".
Laura: Declinaciones.
Steve: Las declinaciones.
Laura: O el género de las palabras.
Steve: Si, estudiando esto y
tratando de aprender y memorizar.
Eso no funciona.
Entonces es una combinación
en la que, de vez en cuando
vas a mirar esas terminaciones.
Pero el 80% del tiempo
restante voy a escuchar y a leer.
De vez en cuando voy a revisar
las reglas que ya he olvidado.
Pero yo no puedo pensar
ahora, hablando español.
Yo voy a cometer erros.
Errores.
Erros es en portugués.
Laura: Es normal.
Steve: Si voy a pensar si es esto
o lo otro, no voy a poder hablar.
Entonces sí, es un equilibrio.
No puedo ignorar,
"Yo voy a utilizar der".
Eso no funciona tampoco.
Laura: Eso era
realmente muy extremo.
Pero si, yo creo que
es el punto medio.
Un equilibrio. No volverse loco.
Yo, por ejemplo, me doy cuenta también,
ahora hace un año empecé a aprender sueco.
Y me he dado cuenta de que mi
alemán ha empeorado un poquito.
Pero bueno, lo acepto, ¿sabes?
Yo prefiero hablar más lenguas
que sean un poquito peores,
porque también podría decir:
"Me centro solo en el alemán,
voy a hacer un C2".
Pero eso a mí no me
llena personalmente.
Cada uno tiene como sus
objetivos y ese no es el mío.
Entonces yo estoy contenta,
satisfecha con mi nivel y ya está.
Steve: Estoy completamente
de acuerdo contigo.
La comprensión es
lo más importante.
La mayor cantidad de idiomas
que yo pueda entender, comprender
para mi es lo principal.
Y si yo hablo con errores, a
veces más, a veces menos...
Porque ahora tú estás estudiando el sueco,
con un poco más de errores en el alemán.
Si tú te enfocas en el alemán,
vas a hablar con menos
errores en alemán, más en sueco.
¿Y qué importancia
tiene todo eso?
Laura: Ninguna.
Steve: Ninguna, exactamente.
¿El sueco, es más
fácil que el alemán?
Laura: Bueno, no sé.
A ver, sí.
Yo creo que a mí me
ha ayudado mucho
hablar bastante bien alemán.
Y enseguida ya pues
me puse con podcast y tal.
O sea, eso me motivó mucho.
A mí lo que no me gusta es
esa fase de no entender nada.
Ya me gusta pues, tener
materiales interesantes.
No quiero estar con un material de
"Hola, me llamo tal".
Eso me aburre mucho.
Entonces estuve como
un mes así con Duolingo,
un poco con un libro que tenía.
Y ya me puse podcasts
fáciles de A1 o así,
y ahora estoy con unos podcasts
de A2-B1 y lo entiendo todo.
Luego hablar, claro...
me cuesta un poco más.
Porque es todo input, input,
input y luego sale el output
pero a veces sale
bien y otras no tanto.
Pero bueno ya está.
Steve: No me digas que tu no
has utilizado LingQ para el sueco.
Laura: Si, si lo he utilizado.
Steve: Las minis
stories para empezar.
Siempre utilizo las mini stories
para comenzar cada idioma.
Laura: Si, de hecho, estoy pensando
en hacer un experimento con LingQ.
Tal vez para aprender
una nueva lengua.
Steve: Okey, muy bien.
Laura: Es que, le
quiero dedicar tiempo.
Ese es un poco el problema.
Lo de los podcasts me va
muy bien porque, por ejemplo,
mientras me preparo el
desayuno me pongo un podcast.
Estoy en el coche,
me pongo un podcast.
Eso como que se adapta
mucho a mi vida, la verdad.
Steve: Vamos a terminar.
A mí me parece que
hay gente que dice
que necesita un talento
para aprender idiomas.
Finalmente necesitamos entusiasmo.
Y lo que se siente hablando
contigo, es tu entusiasmo.
Laura: Ah, gracias.
Steve: Con entusiasmo todos
podemos aprender cualquier idioma,
o cualquier cantidad de
idiomas que queramos.
Laura: Si, yo creo
que es realmente...
perdona.
Que creo que es
entusiasmo y una dedicación.
A mí lo que me
fascina del libro,
no sé si conoces el libro
"hábitos atómicos" (Atomic habits).
Es un libro que a mi
me encantó y de hecho,
después de leer ese
libro empecé con el canal,
empecé a aprender italiano, etc.
Porque con pequeños cambios,
con pequeñitos pasitos
llegas a grandes cambios.
Y eso es lo que
hago yo con el sueco.
10 minutos al día mínimo,
es mi rutina diaria.
Y entonces tengo esa regla
y eso me ayuda un montón.
Steve: Si, si, si.
Exactamente.
Bueno ahora vamos a hacer
una entrevista en tu canal,
donde vamos a hablar
en varios idiomas.
Laura: Si, perfecto.
Gracias Steve.
Steve: Muchas gracias.
Gran placer.
Laura: Adiós.
Steve: Adiós.